tesla's rising share price made elon
musk the richest person in the world
this year but he's not the only member
of the musk family cashing in his
younger brother kimball is worth an
estimated 700 million dollars like elon
kimball grew up in south africa and came
to north america for college after
graduating the brothers co-founded zip2
a software company that was acquired by
compaq in 1999. after that kimball
invested in x.com elon's next startup
which eventually became a part of paypal
kimball joined tesla's board the same
year elon invested 6.5 million dollars
to become the company's largest
shareholder and chairman of the board
he's since invested in tesla with his
own cash and has also been granted
valuable stock options over the years as
compensation for his board service while
the exact number has never been
confirmed we do know that since tesla's
2010 ipo he sold nearly 230 million
dollars pre-tax worth of tesla shares
that includes a massive stock sale
earlier this month right before tesla's
stock price sank 12 percent after elon's
twitter poll elon's younger brother also
owns about two million dollars worth of
stock in chipotle where he's also a
director and likely has a stake in
spacex where he sits on the board but he
very much has his own path outside of
his brother's companies kimball is also
a restaurateur and an investor in the
food space he co-founded the kitchen
restaurant group which operates three
farm-to-table restaurant chains across
the country he also co-founded urban
farming startup square roots in 2016 and
has invested in meal subscription
service every table and lab-grown meat
company upside foods among other
startups kimball also started big green
a non-profit that creates gardens at
schools and aims to teach students about
nutrition health and food literacy
you